good morning Hank it's Tuesday October
16th the second day of teen read week by
the way Hank when do you think adult
read week is I bet if you look at the
average teenager and the average adult
the average teenager has read more books
in the last year than the average adult
now of course the adult would be all
like I'm busy I got a job I got stuff to
do whatever read I mean you're watching
CSI Miami why are you watching CSI Miami
when you could be reading CSI Miami the
novelization Hank in honor of teen read
week I'm going to tell you something
that I should have told you several
months ago I haven't been entirely
honest with you
you may remember that a few months ago I
got really excited about having
cataloged my home library and then I
said I was giving you a tour of my
catalog home library well Hank the truth
of the matter is that I used a lot of
movie magic and ended up only giving you
a very abridged tour of my home library
but now I would like to give you the
full tour of my home library we start
out with poetry Hank you got your e
comings your Shakespeare your Dante your
Norton Anthology of poetry your Dorothy
Parker etc then we've got reference
reference reference reference I love the
quote books you know I like almanacs it
occurs to me that on the long list of
nerdy things I've said in my life I like
almanacs is near the top then you've got
Islam and Christianity separated by the
wicker basket that keeps them from
fighting with each other down here
you've got books that are either by or
about a member of our family then you've
got some foreign language books wicker
basket then you've got Buddhism Hinduism
over there you got some Judaism and then
you've got the Social Sciences over here
you've got graphic novels plays and
stuff about how to write screenplays I
wonder why I have books about how to
write screenplays then on the bottom
shelf because I'm not an egotist you've
got author copies of my books Looking
for Alaska and an abundance of
katherines and then finally in the
office over here at the bottom we have
all of my children's books then in the
living room we have foreign editions of
Looking for Alaska first editions of
fiction by living authors first editions
of books that are either by my favorite
authors or by dead people come to think
of it I don't know why I lumped my
favorite authors with dead people that's
not very nice
then down here we've got southern
studies which includes that Brotherhood
2.0 classic will you miss me when I'm
gone from your pants and then over here
we also have science and technology
which includes the making of the atomic
bomb in your pan
here we have art books miniature chairs
more art books more miniature chairs and
art history books my favorite art
history book volatile bodies in your
pants and then at the bottom we have
history books here we have fiction by
living authors and then here we have
some young adult literature short story
collections mystery novels food memoirs
and then down here is essay collections
literary criticism and humor and then
down here at the bottom there's a
special shelf that for some reason only
contains the diary that I kept when I
was nine years old and the book
everything you need to know about the
goth scene in your pants Hank do you
think we have time for a quick reading
from my childhood diary I think we do
you're going to have a tough time
deciphering my handwriting so let me
read it to you
October 16 1984 today was the best day
my brother got sick thus ends the entry
over here we have fiction by dead people
and books about boxing here are some
books about other sports and games some
books by Mark Twain and the Travel
section and then of course finally we
have my collection of first editions of
books about conjoined twins which is not
even to mention my extensive collection
of books about conjoined twins that
aren't first editions which are
scattered about social sciences in
fiction I don't wanna brag Hank but I've
read more books about conjoined twins
then there are actual living conjoined
twins in the world and that Hank is the
truly exhaustive tour of my home library
so happy teen read week Hank and hooray
for books which never forget to be
awesome I'll see you tomorrow